until goes around comes around earlier
today congresswoman from Colorado Lauren
bobert introduced articles of
impeachment against Joe Biden citing a
dereliction of Duty abuse of power over
the out-of-control Border crisis the
house ultimately voted along party lines
to refer the Articles to vote the
homeland security and Judiciary
committees Congressman bobert joins us
now with more details uh congresswoman
I tend to agree that if a president
takes a pledge to uphold the
Constitution that means the laws of our
country and you don't get to pick and
choose which you uh want to enforce and
that's exactly what he's done down at
the border but I do feel I need to give
you a chance to respond to Professor
dershowitz if you heard him
uh yes I did hear the professor and the
founders designed impeachment as a
built-in accountability mechanism for
such a time as this when a president is
ignoring the duly enacted laws passed by
Congress then it's our duty to act and
be that check and balance on the
executive by deliberately choosing to
ignore Congressional enacted laws Biden
is trampling on our constitution
congress's job is to pass the law the
president's job is to enforce it full
stop by unilaterally nullifying border
security laws Joe Biden has threatened
our constitutional separation of powers
and his oath of office all right let's
talk a little bit now it's been referred
to the homeland security committee and
the house Judiciary Committee that's Jim
Jordan's committee where does it go from
there
well first of all Sean I I just want to
say as as a mother it breaks my heart to
watch Joe Biden turn a blind eye to the
victims of child sex trafficking the
tens of thousands of children that have
gone missing from being trafficked I've
been to the Border I've seen children in
cages wrapped in mylar blankets Joe
Biden is responsible and it breaks my
heart that he has caused these children
to suffer to pursue his radical open
borders Lawless agenda for Joe Biden
these children
you're 100 right and and human
trafficking the fentanyl that's killing
our kids and you know massive numbers of
people and uh they seemingly don't care
they haven't lifted a finger to stop it
as a matter of fact they're aiding and
abetting in in the law breaking
um I'd be negligent if I didn't ask you
all right what's going on with you and
congresswoman Marjorie teller green
Sean I did not put my life on pause and
leave my four boys and my now grandson
um to come here and just get in in spats
with people I I came here to legislate
and to be effective for coloradans
coloradans who are suffering from the
Democrats policy Marjorie is not my
enemy Joe Biden's policy the Democrats
that is my enemy that I am combating
right now and I'm doing everything I can
to make sure I put them in check and
hold them accountable and take our
country back from this radical extremism
that we are seeing and that's why Sean
for the first time in 24 years a house
Republican majority voted today
unanimously Republicans voted to begin
impeachment proceedings against a
current president I jump started this
critical effort to ensure that Joe Biden
is impeached for his unconstitutional
dereliction of Duty violating Article 2
of The Constitution by failing to
execute our immigration and border
security laws and my articles of
impeachment like you said they're
referred to the homeland security
committee and the Judiciary Committee so
we can expedite these impeachment
proceedings against Joe Biden all right
congresswoman great to have you as
always thank you for being with us we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else